هذه واحده من العائلات التي ينص مشروع
عمده كالاك على استقدام المزيد منها الى
البلده لدمجها في المجتمع من خلال مهنه ما
ربيعه ومحمد سوريان كرديان من عين عرب وصل
الى هنا قبل عام مع اولادهما الاربعه قبل
ان تنقسم البلده حول استخدام اللاجئين
لبنان
على فرنسا سلمونا بيت الحمد لله البيت كل
شيء موجود بقلبه فورا حط اولادي بالمدرسه
والحمد لله اتعلم اللغه الفرنسيه وكل
المبسوطين منه المدرسين والانسات وانا
الضيعه اللي هاي اللي فيها انا باشكرهم عن
جد كلهم محترمين
باستفتاء حول استخدام المزيد منهم ويرى
بعضهم مدعوما من حزب استرداد فرنسا الذي
يتزعبه اليمين المتطرف اليكزمور ان
اللاجئين تهديد لهويه بلدهم
يذهب احد الى محطه القطار سانشاغل في
مارسيليا يلاحظ ان لا احد هناك يتحدث
الفرنسيه
الى بلدنا عليهم ان يحترموا قيامنا على
بعد مئات الامطار تظاهره تدعمها قوى
اليسار راى مشاركون فيها ان استقبال
لاجئين يغني ثقافه فرنسا وراى اخرون انه
يجب استقبالهم بشكل افضل
فوتوشوب
استقبال اللاجئين الذين يطرقون ابوابنا
هربا من الحرب والجوع
من الطريقه التي عملتهم بها فرنسا يجب
استقالهم بانسانيا قبل ان تنفض التظاهره
المعاديه للمهاجرين انضم اليها شبان من
بينهم ملثمون راحوا يهتفون فرنسا لنا قبل
ان تطاردهم الشرطه التي استخدمت الغاز
المسيله للدموع لمنع الاحتكاك بين
التظاهراتين
اذا الاولى مع فرنسا المنفتحه وضد الفاشيه
والمستعده لمساعده الذين يحتاجون الى
المساعده والاخرى تظاهره مع فرنسا
المتضامنه مع نفسها فقط والتي يخشى
المشاركون فيها من غزو يهدد ثقافتها هذا
البلد وحضار فوق والنموذج حسين قنيبر
العربيه من قريه كلاك غرب فرنسا